and then on the ride home this is what
Eric did and this is the nicest thing
anyone could ever do yeah that's the one
Johnny happened oh yeah
Eric yeah yeah oh great what a super
discos yeah you didn't go you don't go
no I went to some of those places I just
didn't go to that thing you didn't go
with that with me and uh those guys
Kamil is his name yeah I love the
gangster yeah Rosie's weed when I went
again yeah we had just like left and
then the then they raided his place like
the next day Wow can you imagine I mean
you walk into a white beautiful mansion
and then there's like Newsies and later
yeah it's crazy yeah but so what Eric
Griffin did for me was um Ahmed lied to
me and he said that we were gonna have
business class flying back uh uh let me
step by the way you wanna talk about a
diva he was about you you you I have a
videotape of you being like this Bobby
is funny on stage
okay he really is Bobby's really funny
on stage I got big energy but like if
you let him be in his element off stage
and like just how you are about things
is there's nothing funnier than that you
know it's just like you are just flights
about everything I can cosign Oh God the
bus I have it all on tape
Bobby just looking at the camera do you
smell that what'd it smell like no just
it just and then he would do like this
say you're some Arab guy he would be
like do you smell that look over yeah
this guy all the time so it was like so
then he was I agree with you though a
lot of [ __ ] was promised we were
supposed to be in first class didn't
happen so aren't so on the flight home
and how long's that flight 16 hours 17
17 hours okay we get to the airport and
I get coach middle seat Oh for 17 hours
and I have panic attacks so I there's
just no way I was like
I guess I'm gonna live here and not
Beirut yeah I mean but there's another
little part of the story I mean after
stepping I gotta get okay this is the
part you forget Bobby decides to pay the
three thousand dollars to upgrade
himself to a first-class so he pays the
money and he walks to first class like
this see you [ __ ] then the credit
card was denied he had a moment of life
yeah yeah I remember that and then I
came back you came back and I was having
a panic he was crushed and Eric Griffin
goes listen man I have an aisle you can
have my aisle I'll sit in the middle
Wow seventeen hours as soon as he said
I'm about to get emotional as soon as he
said that that's it not just he is a
life guy and by the way even after him
being a complete [ __ ] but I saw that
this was gonna be a thing for him and I
was like eight months ago his travel
agent made the mistake and he got the
same seat a center a middle seat and he
basically said I'm going to cancel the
whole gig I'm gonna cancel the whole
[ __ ] gig and I'm gonna get off the
[ __ ] plane right now through an
absolute [ __ ] fit because I'm gonna tell
you why no baby
okay it's the principle yeah I'm going
okay I had certain things I don't fly
first-class when I do gigs okay I fly
regular regular okay but you're only
like three foot so regular is like yeah
exactly apartment exactly and also it's
like I know where I'm at in life right
and it would be ridiculous for me and to
get first-class everywhere okay I could
probably afford it but it's just
ridiculous right but I do demand a
window seat and that's it and my [ __ ]
people will give me
it'll give me an airline that never
heard of east north or something like
you I mean hello Wes Wes yeah yeah and I
I just drew the line I go if I'm in the
middle seat and you [ __ ] up I'm not
gonna get on the flight
that's it yeah all right I've been in
this business for 20 [ __ ] years and
it's not like I go to the B room I'm
going to a room and I'm selling tickets
you don't man like I'm selling out rooms
so it's like get me a window that's it
go ahead I'm with you yeah yeah yeah you
should go as far as to say you only want
to fly a certain airline no I do that -
I don't do Southwest no more West Jeff
yes yet I had to tell my guy like it was
like this is what they like to do
they'll get you a gig and then they'll
be like let's say they get a gig that's
a month out and they're like we had to
get the airfare I'm like whoa this is
not enough money for the airfare well
then they go on their thing oh well we
found something on night it yeah yeah
yeah yeah because I have status one
United I'm gonna get upgrades I could
take three luggage on the plane I cannot
stand in lines that [ __ ] is important
yeah especially if you guys are on the
road that are my comfort is important
[Music]